[Musique]
nous on souhaite une réforme passe et
nous sommes les seuls à avoir mis une
proposition très clair sur la tête et
prendre une mesure d'âge courageuse le
vrai courage et là c'est ce que
proposent les républicains et la vraie
justice c'est un régime financé et cette
argile qui ne se finance pas sur le dos
des générations futures
la justice intergénérationnelle et les
majeures il n'y a rien dans le texte
allait de reculade en reculade une
réforme qui est en tout cas pour les
républicains et pour les français est
totalement illisible et incompréhensible
chaque jour qui passe on est davantage
dans le flou situation de fracturation
de notre pays est absolument dramatique
et il est certain que c'est aussi
l'échec d'une méthode politique qui est
celle d' emmanuel macron et emmanuel
macron et son gouvernement sont devenus
des éléments irritant de notre société
nous appelons urgemment à ce que le chef
de l'état prône la concorde et la
réconciliation nationale quand on voit
les chiffres sur lol la sécurité
l'explosion de la délinquance
l'explosion sur l'immigration il ya un
vrai sujet sur la place beauvau sur les
questions de la demande d'asie oui on a
une augmentation de cet ennemi pour cent
de la demande d'asile en france alors
qu'une fois plus partout ailleurs en
europe
elle diminue et que la france et pour la
première fois devenue le premier pays
d'europe pour le demande d'asile jamais
l'immigration n'a été aussi importante
qu'en france il dit depuis l'élection de
monsieur macron presque 800 mille titres
de séjour ont été donnés dans notre pays
la france devienne un pays attractif
nous c'est que de toute façon si on
arrive et qu'on ait débouté deux
magazines on est sûr de quasi pas être
renvoyés et et à partir de ce moment là
eh bien je suis désolé on est dans un
pays qui est en train de vivre une vague
migratoire que nous pouvons plus
supporter et dont les français en ont
ras-le-bol de changer les règles
des dévaluations des résultats deux mois
avant les élections municipales de se
concentrer uniquement encore une fois
sur la france des villes
seule la france des villes présentent un
intérêt pour le président de la
république
en dessous ça n'a pas d'importance et
puis surtout on veut pas on veut pas et
re regarder de trop près pour éviter en
or tirs de chars le apparaissent la
victoire des républicains lors de ces
municipales on publie une pseudo
circulaire qui relève de la basse
manoeuvre politicienne électorale nous
avons par ailleurs de bons candidats et
aujourd'hui je suis effectivement plutôt
confiant parce que c'est une élection
qui ne correspond aussi c'est celle des
territoires
[Musique]